[Music]
you said you did not personally receive
documents from mr. Oher but the FBI did
is that correct and you also said the
FBI got documents from a different
source in mid-september
different source than whom different
source from mr. Orr it was not mr. Orr
who provided the initial documents that
I became aware of in mid-september mr.
Orr did not hand you the dossier
that's mr. Orr didn't hand me anything
mr. all provided information to the FBI
that included material that is what
everybody's calling the dossier since
again mr. Orr provided what he provided
some elements of reporting that my
understanding is originated from mr.
Steele
so Bruce or did give the FBI information
relative to the dossier yes
Wow that pause was very revealing one of
the more explosive revelations during
today's marathon house hearing with
disgraced FBI agent Peter struck joining
us now with more Ohio Congressman Jim
Jordan oh by the way congressman Jordan
welcome to the club if you support
Donald Trump you had to know the lies
the smears against you are obviously a
political attack yeah some of that yeah
you've been through you know what it's
like so thank you today I know what
everyday it's all exactly anyone that's
the president right and you and your
family have to go through that thank you
today think about that topic D yeah D
top DOJ official Bruce or actually hands
parts of the dossier to the FBI and
remember Bruce ORS wife Nellie worked
for fusion GPS who was paid by the
Clinton campaign to put this entire
dossier together this is the first time
to my knowledge that the FBI has
admitted they got parts of the dossier
from boost Bruce or a fellow DOJ
employee that's scary and the wife of
Bruce or wasn't she one of the ones that
work for fusion GPS that summer the
money that was funneled through Perkins
cuy that hired the foreign national
and that got Russian lysing Oh Russia
tried to impact the election through
Hillary is that not true exactly Bruce
or fourth ranking official the
department just
his wife works for fusion GPS in the
summer he gets information passes it to
the FBI that becomes the basis to spy on
the Trump campaign plain and simple this
is the first time to my knowledge the
FBI has admitted that and it was good
that we got some of that information out
today so this this whole investigation
has this notion yeah well yeah yeah he
hesitated you sure yeah you don't want
to answer your question
sure did it well it took me three rounds
to get it out of him but I'll tell you
what this investigation started flawed
with the dossier and Matt Gaetz had some
great questioning where when Muller gets
rid of struck it's now flawed on the
backend as well because Bob Muller
didn't even ask Peter struck about all
these text messages that show his animus
to Donald Trump to President Trump so
Bob Bob Mullen wind today fired him it
was like a 15-minute meeting he didn't
even get into the fact that that Peter
struck had written all these terrible
things about our president he didn't
even get into that so this thing was
flogged when it started on this dot
based on this dossier and it's flawed
here at the end based on when they got
rid of struck and didn't ask him
important questions just just like
Andrew Weissman who lost tens of
thousands of Americans their jobs
overturn nine o Supreme Court for
innocent people sent to jail for a year
overturned by Fifth Circuit all and gets
excoriated by a judge for withholding
exculpatory evidence he's on Team Muller
and there's no team in America that
could ever be fair with the pit ball
like that let me ask you this at the
heart of this was Hillary's
investigation rigged so the favored
candidates investigation rigged and was
this a specific attempt to basically
steal an election pretty much the smelly
people don't let them win yeah well we
always thought that Clinton
investigation was rigged now that what
we've learned in the last several months
and from the inspector general's report
we know it was rigged and the same
people who ran that ran the Russian
investigation they started the rushed
investigation based on this dossier this
was such a key element to getting the
the warrant the secret warrant to spy on
Carter page associated with the Trump
campaign so it surely looks flawed from
the get-go in that investigation as well
Sean
congressman thanks for being with us
I'll tell you this